Good afternoon everybody. Today for the
toxic Google series we have with us,
Lauren May bury the lead singer of the
band churches as well as the rest of the
band who will be playing
a musical set at the end
coming onto the scene,
coming onto the scene two
years ago with their song lies.
There's subsequent single, the mother
we share as well as their debut album,
the bones of what you believe
helped propel churches to
the top five of BBC sine
of 2013 and award winning appearance at
south by southwest and a worldwide tour.
Please join me in welcoming churches.
[inaudible].
Now,
most recently,
I think a lot of the audience is expecting
to see you guys at outside lands. But,
uh, I hear there was a little
issue. Don't bring it up. No. Okay.
No, we're still quite silent
about it to be honest.
From what I heard, it was
the airport's fault. So
yeah, it was a catalog of
disasters within an airport. Um,
and then there was quite an upsetting
bit where me and Martin got on the plane
and could see everybody else at the gate,
but they wouldn't let them on the plane
even though we could see them in the
window.
And then we sat on the runway
for 45 minutes while they
offloaded all their bags,
but they weren't allowed in. The
Dick is very upset, but it's okay,
we're going to try and um,
get a show in San Francisco.
So at the store it was an extra,
but she not have one.
We haven't figured out exactly when yet,
but,
well, I think we're all
looking forward to it then.
Yeah, no, it's okay.
We don't know when it might happen.
We hope will happen.
All right.
So a year ago you wrote an article for
the Guardian about the perils of being a
front woman in a band
in the social media age.
Now as a band born on the Internet,
I take it that social media and be
able to communicate with your fans is
incredibly important to you guys.
But at the same time,
this also opened up some avenues for,
you know,
abusive comments well beyond just
normal musical criticism. Uh,
could you talk a little bit about how you
guys use social media to interact with
fans and the experiences that led you
to write the article for The Guardian?
Yeah. Well, I guess for
us, we came about, um,
getting signed in a kind
of reasonably [inaudible].
We didn't go about the traditional kind
of a tour to the UK for her many years
and then tour of Europe and so on.
We came to a lot of people's attention
because of online streaming and blogs and,
um, people just passing the songs to
each other on social networks. So, um,
we operated on,
signed for quite a long time and it
was just important for us to use those
things as a medium to communicate with
people, give them information. And, um,
I kind of grew up in the MSN era of being
on like band message boards and street
teams and things like that.
So from my point of view,
social networks for those are kind of
like online street teams, I guess. Um,
and there's been definitely overwhelmingly
positive parts of that for us. But, um,
cause we oversee that ourselves. I suppose
when you're logging in to do all the,
do all those things,
sometimes you get a little a rape threat
over your breakfast and that's fine.
But um, well it's not fine I
guess is the point. So, um,
we just kind of posted a screen grab of
like an example that we got sent. Um,
and it wasn't even some anything terribly,
terribly offensive. And I was like,
this is just generally the tone of
some of this stuff. Please stop. Um,
and then the Guardian gives us the
opportunity to expand on it a bit. Um,
and I think the response was generally
positive to us from people in vans or uh,
people in the shows. But, um,
I don't know if it changed the
world in any revolutionary way,
but I guess a speaking of it
is probably quite helpful.
And then figuring out the old people
actually it'd be with you on the world
isn't actually just full of horrible
abusive Internet trolls is good too.
It's good to know.
So Youtube just recently changed its
policy on allowing anonymous names for a
leaving comments. You can now
leave in a comment anonymously.
I want to know your opinion on why
they're, you know, that will affect any,
do you think that'll affect anything or
is this something that's going to happen
regardless of if a people's names
are associated with their messages
so they can,
he's not making you
leave one's anonymously.
I have never actually left a comment on
youtube in my life ever decided like,
well, it'd be weird thing to do.
Um, but um, yeah I don't know.
I guess I was thinking
about this earlier and it's,
but like I think for me it was like it's
a bit personal responsibility and then
who's responsible for that? If people
are posting abusive things, who,
who's the full guy for that?
Is that the children networks or is
it the person or like should like law
enforcement be talking about
that? The who is responsible. Um,
and I think where people are allowed
to be anonymous kind of means that they
feel like there's less of
a follower or something.
And I feel like to an extent when
people are on the Internet, no offense,
because I know you guys are
the Internet. Um, they kind of,
there's a certain level of
where you are removed from that.
So maybe you don't feel as much
personal responsibility or something.
I'm not sure I'm worried about that.
Okay.
Uh,
you also talk about one of the,
this problem stemming from kind
of a lack of empathy on the, uh,
on the side of the people who are
leaving the comments. Um, you know,
here at Google we have
a very global reach. Uh,
and I was wondering if there's any
suggestions you have for either Google or
really the industry in general about how
to kind of promote a sense of empathy
in our,
in our applications and you know,
we're really changing the way that people
interact, bring it online and you know,
it'd be great to kind of bring that sense
of wellbeing that we have in real life
online.
Yeah.
I guess anything like that is helpful.
I think trying to train
the tone of conversations,
but I guess in my mind it's
more the stuff that we received,
it just a more exaggerated version
of what happens in real life.
So it's a kind of chicken
and egg thing for me.
Does that reflect society
or does a society reflect
or it's kind of hard to tell
which,
but um,
I don't think that threatening and
abusive content exists only online.
People probably wouldn't say as
much of that right to your face.
But then there's a reason like why people
think it's okay to say those things
because there's a certain thread
throughout society then makes people think
that's fine.
Like it's not like the only time I've
ever had anybody say anything offensive or
sexist to me is in this band,
on the Internet that happens to people
at the time I am what was coming out of a
subway in Glasgow and somebody,
it was like the last time we at night
and someone showed me his penis and said,
do you think you're too good for it?
Darlin which is funny now maybe.
But at the time I was like,
hmm,
I was like 21 coming home
from work and I was like,
it's not funny when you're there on the
receiving end of that so to speak. Um,
so I don't on what do you say? I
was like, I can't, like I have no,
I'm like five foot two.
It was like 1130 at night.
He's a massive guy and had two other
inmates with the warm I specifically by
that. So, um, yeah, maybe he goes around
leaving horrible comments on the Internet.
I don't know. Or maybe he's busy doing
it in real life. It's hard to say
like,
so for obviously you chose to,
to speak up a part of the article is that
you're not just going to quote unquote
deal with it,
uh,
as a lot of people told you to do when you
wrote the article originally, uh, what,
what side of the problem do
you think stems from, from say,
other female celebrities or other women
in general? Just kind of dealing with it?
Um,
cause I feel like people wouldn't tell
you to do that if it wasn't the majority
of the people who are just kind of
dealing with it. Uh, so to speak.
And what problems stem from that?
Well, I guess, um,
I think it was confusing for me was
that like most people were supportive of
what we were saying,
but there was a definite strain in the
conversation where people were saying
like,
the onus is on,
the onus is on us to accept it and
deal with and things like that.
And that to me is just like a followup
from a victim blaming culture where
people are like,
well it's up to you to deal with it.
It's not up to those people
to not behave like that.
It's up to you to suck
up and deal with it.
And I guess the thing that I was
finding, I was like, it's bad.
It's awful if that's happening to you
when you're using the internet in a
personal capacity.
Cause everyone has the right to use the
internet to seek out knowledge and you
know, do nice stuff on the
Internet. But, um, I was like,
this is something we're doing
in the course of our employment.
So if I want to be in a band
and have a social network,
then I need to accept that.
And I think that's a queen pretty
confusing way to look at it.
Um,
and also,
I suppose probably a lot of people don't
want to talk about that because I think
it paints you in a certain
light or something like that.
But I guess for me it was like these are
things that we think personally anyway
and something you we're coming up against
in your day to day job and then your
day to day life.
So I don't really see why you should
have to sacrifice doing things that you
would normally do in order to appease
what I hope is a minority of people.
And so, uh, at least in terms
of the Google properties,
we can detect and delete comments that
would probably be considered abusive
pretty easily.
But at the same time was that obviously
you wouldn't see them then and that
would give you some sense of relief.
But is there,
do you think it's only going to encourage
the problem if people feel like they
can leave these comments and then they're
actually going to be deleted before
they show up? So that you know, kind of
generates anger on, on and, and you know,
mean harboring feelings towards you, you
know, on, on the side of the commenters.
Do you think the leading these comments
would help fix the problem or is it
um, I don't know, like, um,
I thought about it a lot when we were
trying to figure out how to deal with it.
And so it was like,
yes,
it does make me feel better if
I don't see any of these things.
But then I was like the option then in
order to not see those things as to not
partake in that part of the job
and not do that. And I guess
the always kind of, uh, gets,
gets my back up quite a lot when people
bring up the freedom of speech thing.
I like, well, freedom of hateful
speech is that, is that a load?
And then I think there is a freedom
of speech issue. But I don't,
from my point of view,
it's not the commenters freedom of speech.
It's our freedom of speech to
go about doing what we're doing.
And in order to do that,
then your have to exempt someone talking
to you like that. So I don't, um, yeah,
whenever people bring up the Yep,
I can see what I want because it's a
free world and I'm on the Internet,
but you should feel free to say what
you want but not be a prick. I don't,
I feel like that should be like me.
You need to write that into like the
European Convention on human rights or
something. Freedom of speech brackets. But
not if you're, but um, yeah, I don't know.
I guess you can't, how do you change it?
And I think it's great that, you know,
companies like yourselves are trying to
make a statement on something like that.
But I feel like there's probably quite
a long way to go before it trickles down
into actual day to day attitudes.
You talked about some of the,
uh,
like the story you had of experiencing
this in real life as well.
Would you consider kind of these abusive
comments online and evolution of,
of catcalling or you know, other
kind of street harassment? Uh,
or is this kind of its own separate thing?
I think it's probably
a volts from the same,
the same beginning point
that the middle senses,
it comes from the same starting point.
I think the same kind of attitude, um,
that if, uh, if a woman
is in a public place,
then she's up automatically
opening herself up to these things.
But I guess the distance,
um,
created between people on the
Internet helps people. Maybe.
I've never had anyone see to my face,
you think this is where your culture,
you will know this until
I come run and rape you.
But they'd do something Internet.
If someone said that to me in real life,
I'd would be very alarmed and you would
obviously report them to the police.
But if it's on the Internet and then
people are like, oh, it's, you know,
it's just the Internet says harmless,
it's fine. You're like, mm. Hmm. Is it,
um, so either kind of before you
wrote the article or afterwards,
did you have any mentors either in
the industry or in your life that had
previous experience with something like
this and we're able to help walk you
through it?
Or is that,
is that something that you think maybe
the music industry or earthy things in
general need to have accessible?
MMM,
I guess I didn't really have,
um,
didn't really speak to
anybody about it in that way.
I guess there's always people have
admired in terms of musicians and how they
conduct themselves professionally
and things like that. But, um,
I guess it would have been good if
Lou was like a kind of how to guide.
I wrote that you could be like,
what was this? Right. I got to Dok,
we'll score it at that page and then, oh,
right, okay. Just ignore it. Okay. Um,
but yeah, I don't know. An atheist,
that's probably why it was, um,
it was so confusing,
I suppose because although ever we're
really supportive of each other.
I am the only woman in this band and
they've always been in bands with very
supportive guys, but I've always
been the only female in those bounds.
Although people can empathize with you,
I guess it's not as threatening
because it's not directed at them. Um,
so I dunno,
I guess
I'm not sure like women experience that
on some level at some point in their
lives.
Definitely.
So I guess maybe you learned from
the textbook of life or something,
I'm not sure.
Have you found that these problems have
stemmed more from any specific social
networks in general?
Or is it kind of a broad thing
that you've experienced everywhere?
Like is it harder to be a prick
and 140 characters on Twitter?
Sometimes they are quite inventive
I suppose, but we generally, um,
we've mostly, I would say the
worst one is Facebook, I think.
Which is strange to me because there's
technically more anonymity on Twitter
because you don't need to use your real
name. If your account gets deleted,
you can make another one
like I many hours later.
Whereas I suppose with Facebook they
want you to use your real name if you do.
I don't know. Um, um, but yeah,
that's definitely where most of the,
the comments were coming in.
And also because we still had other point,
the direct message function
on which, um, I think he,
that's in another further removal
for those people. So they're like,
we're contacting you on the Internet and
it can't be seen by other people so I
can see it directly to you.
Whatever I wish to see.
Obviously we figured out how to turn that
off now, so that's much better. But um,
yeah, even now if you post like I think
a reshared an article that was um,
on Ma make website and it was
about an advert in sound on sound.
There was advertising
microphones and it was like, um,
a naked woman like from the side with her.
Like you could see her ass and
stuff in it. And I have two meals.
Like that's not what's that got to
do with advertising microphones.
But it was a really interesting article
that the guy who used to run drone,
his own drop and then underneath it
people would just like shut up and go back
to doing what you're supposed to be doing.
Like I don't want to read this.
I want to come here and listen to music.
I don't want,
why are you talking about this shit?
It's not relevant.
And I was like that articles about music,
I think that is relevant.
But just like seeing all kind of unfold
again. You're like, oh there they go.
That's fine.
But it's great.
I guess the good thing for us now is
that if people know where we stand on it,
they kind of self police
a little bit more.
So rather than us having
to go on and be like,
look at user won't year and goes through,
um,
people can have a more of a discussion
about it. So I guess that's positive,
but I don't really know how much
that actually changes people's minds.
I buy things.
So do you, do you ever respond
directly to these comments?
Maybe in the beginning when you were,
when you first started receiving them
or you generally just try to steer clear
basically any advice you'd have for, for
people who receive these sort of things?
I think it's a difficult line to tread
because my instinct tells me that every
time somebody says it,
then if you were threatened and you need
to go in on the offensive and just call
people out on it,
but I suppose
I've got quite a busy day and most days
and they don't have a huge amount of
time to troll through and be
like, oh great, that's happened.
Most upon them would be like, what would
your mother say? Things like that. But um,
yeah, I don't know. I guess it's just
trying to gauge it on a day to day basis.
I think it was before we
made any comment on it,
it was taking quite a bit of a personal
tool to constantly be the person that
has to be like, no, stop it. No, stop it.
Or just, there's a little got to finals.
I'm just going to delete the, delete
the comments and ban, ban the users.
But can't ban people from life.
So that's a problem.
That sounds really like area and then
like get them on, put them in a bin.
But I don't mean that
in the article you tread pretty lightly
around the word feminist. You, uh,
kind of treated as if maybe you know,
there some connotations that you don't
want to associate with yourself. Um,
you make comment that you don't hate
men in general, that you're speaking,
you know, feminism in terms
of equality for the sexes. Um,
do you think that the term in general
has kind of become unfriendly and
um, well I think the star of the sentence
sentences. I am a feminist because I am,
and I feel like all the cabinets I put
in after that word to counter what people
say to you when you see that, they're
like, oh, so you hate men then, oh, well,
all these other things. And
you're like, no, I don't know.
It's just a stereotype that has been
made to discredit what people are saying
about it, I think. Um,
so I have no problem identifying is
that because to me it means somebody who
seeks equality between all people. It's
not about making women better than men.
It's not about, um, you know, like
Oh, white middle class woman's agenda.
It shouldn't be about that issue to be
about generally society being a bit less
shit sometimes I think.
Um,
and I think there's lots of great examples
of people who are making something
like that more accessible to
people because I guess for me,
I learned about it through,
through music and then I kind of figured
out what those people were reading and
who they were influenced by and that's
how I got into like feminist literature
and stuff.
But if you can feel really the kind of
like academic and strange in that regard.
So I think the Internet has
been really helpful for that.
Like things like feminist thing and
jazzy bell and stuff, making it more,
um, not even necessarily pop culture
based, but just more conversation,
conversational.
And I'm like hopefully more representative
of more people because it's about
your everyday issues.
So it shouldn't just be like in a book,
in a library somewhere.
Okay.
And the,
uh,
kind of what prompted me to reach out
to you guys in the first place was a,
an article I read in the January
issue of Pacific Standard. Uh,
it's about a writer,
Amanda Hess who kind of covers
her experiences with these, uh,
sort of comments. Um, she kind
of talks about how she, you know,
she receives these comments where people
are threatening to come to her house,
uh, which you know of happened
in a real life experience.
If you went to the police with
that, they would, uh, you know,
get a restraining order that
it take some sort of action.
But because she received these
comments, uh, on the Internet,
the police kind of brushed it off. Um,
they, I acted as if it wasn't important.
They told her to get back in touch with
them. If someone actually shows up,
which seems like there's a lot of room
for something bad to happen there.
Do you think as we, as we transitioned
to more digital interactions that we,
that we risk kind of losing some of the
standards and etiquette that we've kind
of built up over the years and that,
you know,
some of the safety might disappear
as these things go online.
I Dunno.
I guess the,
as the technology develops
in society changes,
then laws need to adapt to cater for that.
Um,
bicycles right now is a pretty big
gray area because if they're like,
they're like,
no physical threat has happened upon you,
then what can the police
really do about it?
But then I just think it adds to the
people feeling more alone and more
vulnerable and more
isolated. Um, and I suppose
the thing with, with that is
even if like, I guess Amanda has,
you can find her own lane.
She's pretty well known,
but even if it was like a
conventional stalking thing,
the victim still doesn't have,
I think that's what she says in the piece.
Like the victim doesn't have the anonymity
of the person that's abusing them.
Like, because they are the known person,
whether they're a well known person. No,
we're just,
you know,
you don't have to be a journalist or
in a band or whatever to encounter that
kind of stuff.
So I guess something,
something needs to be done to
figure out what to do about that.
But who knows what it is.
I don't know.
We'll try to figure that out.
Yeah, please. You guys are in charge
of the Internet and so go fix.
I like to open the questions
up to the audience. Uh,
there's a microphone back there.
Hello. Hi. Um, I feel like we spent
a lot about policing and things,
but even with police, bad things
still happen, right? Um, you know,
bullying in playgrounds, for example,
if it's physical abuse, right?
And we can police it as much as we can,
but the police don't stop.
I'm under the assumption that,
you know, not an assumption,
but this is emotional abuse, right?
You being emotionally abused. Um,
this sort of parallel would be a
bodyguard or our physical body guard is a
celebrity.
As a wellness person,
you have a body guard who protects you as
you move around the physical world. Um,
do you think an emotional
body card fee on the Internet,
is there reasonable response?
MMM,
I think that if they existed that would be
nice. But it's pretty abstract. But, um,
I don't know.
I guess that's the gain of that.
You have to kind of do that job yourself.
And I think it's like
separating the personal anguish
sounds really pathetic but
anguish, uh, from, um, from the
profession professional side.
Um, so we'll try not to make a knee jerk
emotional response to something and then
just do the kind of, okay. Block
user, like go through that process.
But um,
yeah,
I suppose it's more difficult to deal
with it cause it's not like a tangible
physical thing.
You,
there's no way of going of like just
putting somebody bigger in the middle
because there really isn't that.
Hmm. Okay. Thank you.
That was a hard question.
I wasn't prepared for that.
Hi. So I just want to maybe
switch gears a little bit,
but I had a question for you guys.
You mentioned at the beginning, um,
how your band started,
like sorta started off with the music
blogs and social media kind of spreading
your name and even your,
the way you spell it,
you did it specifically so that you
can, you know, kind of stand out on,
on the Internet.
Um,
how do you sort of see the music
industry and vans that you see coming up,
you know, that are just
starting out, you know,
utilizing these blogs and social media
and the Internet more so now maybe in the
past. And do you see that sort
of increasing, you know, given,
given the rise of how many people are
kind of plugged in in the digital age
nowadays,
but is that something that you guys kind
of support and promote or is it more so
kind of band by band and,
and however they, you know,
want to want to spread their name?
Um,
I think for me,
I guess as a case by case basis and w
the blueprint in the works for one person
won't work for somebody else.
Um,
and I think certainly for me when I
remember being in bands like pre, pre,
I'm having a nice space that was quite
interesting when you didn't have to like
put your posters on my space
when in light with that. Um,
and I guess you just promoted it in
different ways. Um, bicycles, no,
it's kind of unorthodox if a band doesn't
have a Facebook page and things like
that and you think those things are
differently important tools for us to
communicate with people.
But I've always been the person in the
band that runs social networks for bands
when I've been in them and I try just
as hard at the social networks from my
other bands, but they didn't, uh,
I guess they didn't connect
with people in that same.
So I like to believe it's about the
content as well as the way that we pitched
it. But I think, um, generally speaking,
the music industry is probably having
to adapt a lot to incorporate all these
new technologies.
And I think for a long time people
were just drawn to stand like the,
like a little dot boy with
his finger in the dam being,
I don't know if that meant for it
makes sense here, but um, yeah.
And then just kind of saying no to the
progress because it was changing the way
the industry worked. But I feel
like you can't stop that process.
It's just going to happen.
So the way that labels and things
operate and the way that I even radio and
things like that we'll have to
change because you can't stop,
cannot be internet and her,
it's too late. So, um, you know,
there's a lot of good things have come
out with that. Like without the Internet,
we wouldn't have been able to cover as
much ground as quickly as we have and it
makes it,
I think it makes it a lot more democratic
in some ways because if you have a
certain amount of technology,
you can make things at home
in your bedroom and share
them online and you don't
necessarily have to go through that filter
of in getting the guy in the suit to
listen to it and sign off on it before
you can release it because you can sell
for at least on the Internet.
And that's pretty powerful.
Okay,
thanks.
These are hard. I don't, I looked at
the sheet earlier and I was like, man,
it's fine. Coming from
left field, I don't know.
I have a few questions from some of
the people streaming this as well.
What are the most effective actions
you've seen men take to combat misogyny on
mine?
Um, I think that's an
interesting one because, um,
when men speak to other men about it,
I think sometimes I've seen that be a
lot more effective because when I talk
about it, people could be like, oh,
well she's saying that because she's a
woman or because she's a feminist and
blah, blah, blah, and it's personal to
her. And I don't agree with that argument,
but it's easier to discredit me that way
than it is to a man who's saying that
to you. And I think for me, like, um,
I've gone to meetings with like feminist
groups in Glasgow and then be like, hmm.
Not For me because one of
the conversations was it
was like a feminist book
group at University in one
of the conversations was
whether we could read books
that were written about feminism by men.
And to me, I was like, that's a complete,
it's completely backwards.
I don't want to sit here and be a part
of that conversation because it's not a
conversation to be had in a room full of
people who already agree it should be a
conversation that
everyone's having. So, yeah,
I think if everybody can be involved
in trying to make society a tiny,
tiny bit less rubbish sometimes,
then that would be good.
This from Eric,
would you use something like a spam filter
that automatically labeled aggressive
emails and a more generally,
what do you think about the role of
technology and reducing online massage ne.
Okay.
Um,
I guess spam filter is probably useful
in Sofar as then you wouldn't see as much
of it, but it doesn't necessarily deal
with the root problem because then it's,
I guess it's a way of you dealing
with it rather than going to where it
originated and trying to stop it
happening in the first place. Um,
I guess all right.
I Dunno.
Like I think for me technology is
really has been really useful because we
traveled so much and it enables me to
keep in touch with people and work on the
move. And in the same way it does for
everybody, you can, you know, just simple,
tiny things that make the day
easier and better. And, um,
I think that's a really powerful thing
and I don't want to send to make it sound
like I'm poopooing the internet or
anything cause I'm definitely not. But um,
yeah I think, I guess I don't
know about technology necessarily,
but kind what we were talking about,
the Internet has definitely opened up a
conversation about feminism and misogyny.
Yes. It's probably spiked it
a little bit as well, but um,
if people are talking
about it in the same forum,
then that's probably a good thing.
I feel like you should grade all my
answers or something. I don't know.
Uh, we have a music one as well. Uh,
where do you stand on subscription
music services given that many prominent
artists have spoken out against them,
what do you think we could do to
improve relations with music creators?
I guess that's a pretty, that's
a pretty controversial topic. Um,
and I think that every
artist is completely entitled
to have an opinion on it.
I guess for us it's more difficult to be
very strident about that stuff because
without streaming
services on the Internet,
probably people wouldn't have heard as
much about our band. Um, and there was a,
a gas the other day where the songs came
off Spotify in Mexico and people got
very upset and I'm like, Ooh, sorry,
I go back and fix it. But, um,
I suppose that that's weird
in a way because then you're
like, oh, well you don't,
she don't have my help them,
you can't just and listen to it.
But then I guess it's just a
product of the time to an extent.
Like I didn't grow up in an era where
music streaming was at prominent.
I remember like getting like one one,
I think I did,
I've only ever illegally downloaded one
thing and it was worn during the same
period. We'd have to leave the
computer on for like three days. Um,
and I remember having to debate to debate
with my mom when we were turning the
computer off and I was like, it's
almost there. It's almost there. Um,
and it was just because I couldn't
physically get the song. It was like,
I think it was like a letters to cleo
cover of cheap trick or something that was
in a film and I really wanted it but
couldn't get it. Um, so I guess I don't,
can't relate huge amount to
music streaming in that sense,
but I guess it's about
making,
making all that stuff fair on the artist
because somebody somewhere is making
money out of those things,
but it's definitely not the people
who make the content that's on it.
So I guess if there was a
way of making those streams,
I dunno, somehow feeding the, the
gain back to the people who've paid,
paid in time and money to make
that cause I guess, you know,
at the end of the day someone is trying
to make a living off doing that. Um,
I don't know. I don't know how to, how
to fix it. I don't know what to do.
Audience Question.
Um, so I have a question about what you
see the role of the rest of the online
community is in kind
of combating misogyny.
Because I know sometimes people say
if you comment defending someone,
that brings more attention to it.
Do you think that there's a role that
everyone on the Internet can play and sort
of, you know, defending women,
defending people in general
against these kind of comments?
Do you think that brings more
attention to it in a positive way?
Or do you think that hurts the cause by
cycling back the focus to those negative
comments?
Okay.
I Dunno,
I guess maybe I'm an antagonistic person,
but for me it was like the,
the ignoring thing.
Like when you were a kid and your
mom was life, so that's really,
and you just ignore them. Um, it doesn't,
I guess I don't think that that theory
works here because if you ignore it,
then people aren't going to be like,
oh,
they're ignoring me because I've
done something really offensive.
They're going to think that you're
ignoring them in a kind of, oh, well,
fair enough, kind of
way. Um, and I think if,
yeah,
if people can be respectful of each other,
obviously I'm not saying that you should
go in and we a horrible like awful
person in return because then
that's just an eye for an eye.
But I think if people can call each
other right on those things, then that's,
that's what useful. Um, and
also even in the last like year,
18 months or whatever,
I've noticed loads more stuff about
feminism and mainstream media and that,
I dunno,
is that a trend of what people are writing
about or are the just more willing to
talk about it and more people are thinking
about it? I'm not sure. I hope so,
but um, yeah, hopefully it
won't like disappear again,
like it kind of feminism is the new
black and then it's gone. Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
you mentioned that you like feministing
and jazz bowel and I see them sort of as
a more palatable or
relatable form of feminism,
especially for like our generation,
which I think is changing a lot.
What about them do you really like and
how do you think people can sort of pull
elements of that and to the own their
own content that they're creating online?
That's an interesting
question. I think, um,
for me people like Jessica Valenti are
really important voices because she's
obviously very intelligent,
hadn't has studied the academic side of
all this so she knows she knows all the
theories and she knows all the kind of
the texts that you should check out.
But I think the fact that she's taking
that and putting it in a real life
situation and the,
the tone in which you rates and is
really relatable and she's talking about
things that we've all experienced
and I think feminist thing's really
interesting because they talk
about high court rulings on things,
but then they also talk like have opinion
pieces on things like things that are
happening in pop culture or things
are being talked about in the news.
And I think just kind of having that
kind of dialogue is really helpful and it
feels like a nice,
quite,
quite a useful community
rather than somebody telling
you things and being like,
you think this bid kind of raise questions
and accept comment in return. Um,
and I think that's just makes it
makes you think about stuff. Um,
and I think what, certainly when
I was growing up, I didn't really,
didn't really have a huge
number of friends that would
be interested in the same
kind of things.
Um,
and I think only within the last few
years really of a fund as many like minded
women.
Um,
we kind of make the joke that I started
like a women's collective in Glasgow to
make more friends, to make more
friends who agreed with me. Um,
but I think that has been very important
because it's just a thing we have where
we run live events and have a radio
show and podcast and things. Um,
just focusing on women arts
and music and things like that.
And for me that feels like a positive
thing to do because otherwise I feel like
I'm constantly thinking
about the negative things,
the things that are the horrible things
are happening and constantly happen on
all levels by can I want to try and
change the dialogue in my mind and make it
something more positive and having
people to talk to her about those pretty
helpful. So you don't feel like you're
the only one and you're like, Oh God,
is that, it's not fine. Am I overreacting?
Nope. Nope, it's fine. So yeah,
community is key.
Do we have any more audience questions?
Hello? Um, so, uh, I remember a while ago,
like a comedian once said that
there's a strong power and comedy and
communication,
especially when it comes to tough topics
and need something along the lines of
like, if I make you laugh, then maybe
you won't be as threatened or defensive.
So sometimes I think of
that with music as well.
So I wondered if you'd ever
address these kinds of topics,
topics and your music or maybe you
already have with your lyrics are a bit
cryptic. So sorry. Um, I guess
for like, when, I guess when we write
music for me, like I just write about,
it's like I can have personal perspective,
whether that's on personal events that
happened to you or a personal perspective
on something that's happening externally.
Um,
but I suppose the lyrics
are pretty cryptic,
so you probably can't tell
from any of that. Um, but yeah,
I guess the personal is
political to an extent.
So the political is personal
and vice versa. So, um,
there's probably elements of that and
the stuff that we're writing about by,
I don't think there's necessarily any
anthem's in the same way there is on like
a Latigo record or something.
All right. Uh, well thank you for
coming today. Thank you for having us.
[inaudible]
we're back. Um, and this time
you guys get to actually speak,
so that's nice. Yeah. He had never
gets, we don't let him speak.
No. Yes, we are a bank. Old Churches.
[inaudible]
no.
Oh,
we can just
choose any
open
give you
say we can change,
we can change.
Oh
no
thanks guys.
We are going to play a couple more songs.
Um,
I feel I'm not directly due to pelvic
stuff, public speaking, to be honest.
It makes me quite worried.
Uh,
so if there's a more of a Bronto and
the voice than isn't this debate,
it's just left over from that.
Me,
I'm just looking for someone that
will let me go on one of your slides.
Yeah.
If there's anyone in this room in this,
if there's what have you that I expected
so surely someone can make it happen
for me.
Yeah.
Come all the way here from
Scotland in the name of feminism.
Let them on the slide.
Okay.
You better and from me seeing you
gonna come for you all that I have
a break here. Tiny, tiny.
I never believe,
but I see
uploading your lesson,
sleep.
There is no other way
to get good swing at me.
So full flow.
I tried water.
Are
you stuck in
my back?
Did you
sleep to see
I was not a park and swines
there is no other way.
Say Good,
good swing at me.
So finally we agree.
We're promise
butter
Burger Britain.
It is, you know,
it's also easy.
There is no other way.
Take a swing at me.
So finally we were promised,
well
thanks guys.
We are going to go, we're going to play
one more song and then we're going to go.
Um, I need to rehydrate cause I was
white. It was a lot Joe's experience,
but it's okay. It's not your
fault, it's just psychology.
But thank you again for having us.
Thanks for letting people
look us up on you on you.
It's been very helpful to us.
Um,
one thing is he's running,
he's running.
Yeah.
But yeah,
thank you for having us and for letting
us come and chat about stuff like that
because um,
I think it's really awesome of you guys
to do that and make it be less of a
marginalized thing and thanks
[inaudible]
never,
I keep my lips shut.
I'm the only one.
I would always be free.
Easy.
We're the only ones.
I bet you, even though
you put your head,
it's a service.
Can see
liver,
liver.